the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
last time we left off with a question
having to do with playing with blocks
and this is supposed to get give us a
visceral feel for for something anyway
having to do with series and the
question was whether I could stack these
blocks build a a stack so that I'm going
to try you up I'm already off balance
here see the question is can I build
this so that the let's draw a picture of
it so that the first block is like this
the next block is like this and maybe
the next block is like this and notice
there's no visible means of support for
this block it's completely to the left
of the first block and the question is
will this fall down or at least or more
precisely eventually we'll ask you know
how far can we go now before you answer
this question the claim is that that
this is a kind of a natural physical
question which involves some important
answer no matter whether the answer is
you can do it or you can't so this is a
good kind of math question where no
matter what the answer is if when you
figure out the answer you're going to
get something interesting out of it
because there are two possibilities
either there's a limit to how far to the
left we can go in which case that's a
very interesting number or else there is
no limit you can go arbitrarily far and
that's also interesting and curious and
that's the difference between
convergence and divergence the thing
that we were talking about up to now
concerning series so my first question
is do you think that I can get it get it
so that this thing doesn't fall down
with with it well you see I have about
eight blocks here or so so you can vote
now how many in favor that I can that I
can succeed in doing this sort of thing
with maybe more than three blocks how
many in favor
all right somebody's voting twice there
that's
I like that how about it how about a
post uh
so I that was really close to a tie
alright but I think that there was
slightly more opposed I don't know you
guys who were in the back maybe could
tell anyway it was it was pretty close
alright so now I'm going because this is
a real life thing I'm going to try to do
it alright alright so now I'm going to
tell you what the trick is the trick is
to do it backwards when most people are
playing with blocks they decide to build
it from the bottom up right but we're
going to build it from the top down from
the top down and that's going to make it
possible for us to do the optimal thing
at each stage so when I build it from
the top down the best I can do is well
it'll fall off I need to have it less
you know halfway across that's the best
I can do so the top one I'm going to
build like that I'm going to take it as
far to the left as I can and then I'm
going to put the next one down as far to
the left as I can and then the next one
as far to the left as I can
well I was a little too far and then I'm
going to do the next one
as far to the left as I can and then I'm
going to do the next one well let's line
it up first as far to the left as I can
and then the next one as far to the left
as I can alright now those of you who
are in this line can see all right I
succeeded all right this is that's over
the edge alright so it can be done all
right
all right so now we know that we can get
farther than you know we can we can we
can make it overflow so the question now
is how far can I get okay do you think I
can get to here can I can I get to the
end over here so how many how many
people think I can get this this far
over to here how many people think I can
get this far well and you know remember
I'm gonna have to use more than just
this one more block that I've got I
don't write obviously I'm thinking
actually I do have some more blocks at
home but okay we're not going to but
anyway you think I can get over to here
how many people say yes and how many
people say no more people said no than
yes all right so maybe the the stopping
place is some mysterious number in
between here all right well okay
so now now we're going to do the
arithmetic and we're going to figure out
what happens with this with this problem
in okay well let's let's do it all right
so now again the idea is the idea is
we're going to start with the top the
top block will call that block number 1
and then the farthest if you like to the
right that you can put a block
underneath it is exactly half way all
right well that's not the best job I can
do now in order to make my units work
out easily I'm going to decide to call
the length of the block - all right and
that means with I start at location 0
then the first place where I am is
supposed to be halfway and that will be
1 okay so so the first step in the
process is 1 more to the right or if you
like if I were building up which is what
you would actually have to do in real
life it would be 1 to the left
okay now the next one now here's the the
way that you start figuring out the
arithmetic the next one is based on a
physical principle which is that I the
farthest I can stick this next block
underneath is at what's called the
center of mass of these two which is
exactly halfway here that is there's a
quarter of this guy and a quarter of
that guy balancing each other all right
so that's as far as I can go if I go
farther than that it will fall over so
that's the absolute farthest I can do so
the next block is going to be over here
and a quarter of two is a half so this
is three halves here all right so we
went to one we went to three halves here
and then I'm going to keep on going with
this
eventually all right so we're going to
figure out what happens with this with
the stack question the best way to
optimize the question is how do I know
that this is the best way to optimize I
can't answer that question but I can
tell you that it's the best way if I
start with the top like this and the
next one like this right because I'm
doing the farthest possible at each
stage that actually has a name in
computer science that's called the
greedy algorithm I'm trying to do the
best possible at each stage the greedy
algorithm starting from the bottom is an
extremely bad strategy because when you
do that you stack it this way and it
almost falls over and then the next time
you can't do anything so the greedy
algorithm is terrible from the bottom
but it turns this is the greedy
algorithm starting from the top and it
turns out to do much better than the
greedy algorithm starting from the
bottom but of course I'm not addressing
whether there might not be some other
incredibly clever strategy where I
wiggle around and make it go up that's
I'm not ants to dressing that question
all right it turns out this is the best
you could do but that's not not clear
all right so now here here we have this
thing and now I have to figure out what
the arithmetic pattern is so that I can
figure out what I was doing with those
shapes
so let's let's figure out the sought
experiment here all right
now the thought experiment I want to
imagine to you for you is you've got a
stack of a bunch of blocks and this is
the first n blocks alright and now we're
going to put one underneath it and what
we're going to figure out is the center
of mass of those n blocks which I'm
going to call C sub n okay and that's
the place where I'm going to put this
very next block I'll put it in a
different color here here's the new the
next block over and the next block over
is the n plus first block and now I want
you to think about what's going on here
if the center of mass of the first n
blocks is this number this new one it's
of length 2 and its center of mass is 1
further to the right than the center of
mass that we had before so in other
words I've added to this configuration
of n blocks one more block which is
shifted whose center of mass is not
lined up with the center of mass of this
but actually over farther to the to the
right alright so the new center of mass
of this new block this is the extra
piece of information that I want to
observe is that this thing has a center
of mass at C n plus one it's one unit
over because this total length is two so
right in the middle there is one over
according to my units all right now this
is going to make it possible for me to
figure out what the new center of mass
is so C n plus one is the center of mass
of n plus 1 watts
now this is really only in the
horizontal variable right I'm not I'm
not keeping track of the center of mass
actually this thing is hard to build
because the center of mass is also
rising it's getting higher and higher
but I'm only keeping track of its
left/right characteristic so this is the
x coordinate of it
alright so now here's the idea
I'm combining the white ones the end
blocks with the pink one which is the
one on the bottom and there are n of the
white ones and there's one of the pink
one and so in order to get the center of
mass of the whole I have to take the
weighted average of the two that's n
times CN plus 1 times the center of mass
of the pink one which is CN plus 1 and
then I have to divide if it's weighted
average of the total of n plus 1 blocks
by n plus 1 this is going to give me the
new center of mass of my configuration
at the n plus first stage and now I can
just do the arithmetic and figure out
what this is and the 2 CN is combined I
get n plus 1 times CN plus 1 divided by
n plus 1 and if I combine these two
things and do the cancellation that
gives me this recurrence formula CN plus
1 is equal to CN plus there's a little
extra these two cancel that gives me the
CN but then I also have 1 over 1 plus n
plus 1 that's how much gain I can get in
the center of mass by adding one more
block that's how much I can ship things
over depending on how we're thinking of
things to the left or the right
depending on which direction we're
building them
all right so now I'm going to work out
the formulas first of all c1 that was
the center of the first block
I put its left end at zero the center of
the first block is at 1 that means that
c1 is 1 okay
c2 according to this formula and
actually I worked it out we'll check it
in a sense c2 is c1 plus 1 over 2 right
that's the case N equals 1 so this is 1
plus 1/2 that's what we already did
it's the three-halves number and now the
next one is c2 plus 1/3 that's the
formula again and so that comes out to
be 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/3 and now you can
see what the pattern is CN if you just
keep on going here CN is going to be 1
plus 1/2 plus 1/3 plus 1/4 plus 1 over N
so now I would like you to vote again do
you think I can now that we have the
formula do you think I can get over to
here how many people think I can get
over to here how many people think I
can't get over to here oh there's still
a lot of people do so it's still almost
50/50 that's that's amazing well so
we'll address that in a few minutes so
now let me tell you what's going on this
CN of course is the same as what we
called last time SN and remember that we
actually estimated the size of this guy
this is related to what's called the
harmonic series and what we showed was
that log n is less than s n which is
less than s n plus 1 all right now I'm
going to call your attention to the
read part which is the divergence part
of this estimate which is this one for
the time being
right just saying that this thing is
growing and what this is saying is that
as n goes to infinity log in goes to
infinity so that means that s n goes to
infinity because of this inequality here
it's bigger than log N and so if n is
big enough we can get as far as we like
alright so I can get to here and at
least half of you at least the ones who
voted that was I don't know we have a
quorum here but I'm not sure we
certainly didn't have a majority on
either side anyway this thing does go to
infinity so in principle if I had enough
blocks I could get it over to get it
over to here all right and that's the
meaning of divergence in this case on
the other hand I want to discuss with
you and the reason why I use this
example is I want to discuss with you
also what's going on with this other
inequality here and what its
significance is which is that it's going
to take us a lot of numbers and a lot of
blocks to get up to a certain level in
other words I can't do it with just
eight blocks or nine blocks in order to
get over here I'd have to use quite a
few of them so let's just see how many
it is so I worked this out carefully and
let's see what I got so to get across
the lab tables all right this this
distance here I already did this
secretly but I don't actually even have
enough of these to show you but well one
two three four five six and a half
I guess that's enough so it's six and a
half so it's it's two lab tables it's 13
of these blocks all right so there are
13 blocks which is equal to 26 units
okay
that's how far to get across I need and
the first one is already two so it's
really 26 minus 2 which is 24 which is
that's what I need okay so I need log n
to be equal to 24 roughly speaking in
order to get that far so let's just see
how how big that is all right I think I
work this out
so let's see that means that n is equal
to e to the 24th and if you if you
realize that these blocks are 3
centimeters high okay let's see how many
how many that we would need here that's
kind of a lot let's see it's 3
centimeters times e to the 24th which is
about 8 times 10 to the 8th meters okay
and that is twice the distance to the
moon so um so ok I could do it maybe but
I would need a lot of blocks right
that's not not very plausible here all
right so those of you who voted against
this were actually sort of half right
and in fact if you wanted to get it to
the wall over there which is over 30
feet the height would be about the
diameter of the observable universe it's
kind of kind of a long way there's
there's one other thing that that I
wanted to point out to you about this
shape here which is that if you if you
lean to the left right if you put your
head like this of course you have to be
on your side to look at it this this
curve is is the is the shape of a
logarithmic curve so in other words if
you think of this the vertical is the
x-axis and the horizontal that way is
the vertical is the up direction then
this thing is growing very very very
very slowly if you send the x axis all
the way up to the moon you're still the
graph still hasn't gotten across the lab
tables he
it's only partway there if you go twice
the distance to the moon up that way
it's gotten finally to that end all
right so that's how slowly the logarithm
grows it grows very very slowly and if
you look at it another way if you stand
on your head you can see a an
exponential curve and see so you get
some sense as to the growth properties
of these functions and fortunately these
are protecting us from from all kinds of
stuff that would happen if there weren't
exponentially small tails in the world
like you know I could walk through this
wall which I wouldn't like doing okay
now so this is our last example and and
the important number we fortunate
unfortunately we didn't discover another
important number
there wasn't an amazing number place
where this stopped all we discovered
again is is some property of infinity so
infinity is still nice number and the
theme here is just that infinity isn't
just one thing it's has a character
which is a rate of growth and you
shouldn't just think of there being one
order of infinity there are lots of
different orders and some of them have
different meaning from others all right
well that's the the theme I wanted to do
in just having a visceral example of
infinity now we're going to move on now
to some other kinds of techniques and
this is going to be our last subject
what we're going to talk about is what
are known as power series now we've
already seen our first power series and
I'm going to remind you of that
here we are with power series our first
series was was this one and we mentioned
last time that it was equal to one over
one minus X for X less than one this one
is known as the geometric series I
didn't use the letter X last time I use
the letter A but this is known as a
geometric series now I'm going to show
you one reason why this is true why the
formula holds and it's just the kind of
manipulation that was done when these
things were first introduced and here's
the the idea of a proof so suppose that
this sum is equal to some number s which
is the sum of all of them
these numbers here the first thing that
I'm going to do is I'm going to multiply
by X okay so if I multiply by X let's
think about that I multiply by X on both
the left and the right hand side then on
the left side I get X plus x squared
plus X cubed plus and so forth and on
the right side I get s times X and now
I'm going to subtract the two equations
one from the other and there's a very
very substantial cancellation this whole
tail here gets cancelled off and the
only thing that's left is the one so
when I subtract I get one on the left
hand side and on the right hand side I
get s
time up - s times X all right and now
that can be rewritten as s times 1 minus
X and so I've got my my formula here
this is 1 over 1 minus X is equal to s
now this reasoning is has one flaw it's
not complete and that this reasoning is
basically correct but it's incomplete
because it requires that s exists for
example it doesn't make any sense in the
case x equals 1 so for example in case s
x equals 1 we have 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus
etc equals whatever we call s and then
when we multiply through by 1 we get 1
plus 1 plus 1 plus equals s times 1 and
now you see that the subtraction gives
us infinity minus infinity is equal to
infinity minus infinity that's what's
really going on in the argument in this
in this context so it's just nonsense I
mean it doesn't give us anything
meaningful so the this argument it's
great and it gives us the right answer
but not always and the times when it
gives us the answer the correct answer
is when the series is convergent and
that's why we care about convergence
because we want manipulations like this
to be allowed
so the good case this is the red case
that we were describing last time it's
the bad thing but what we want is the
good case the convergent case and that
is the case when X is less than 1 so
this is the convergent case now okay so
there are there are much more detailed
things to check exactly what's going on
but I'm going to just say general words
about how you recognize convergence and
then we're not going to worry about so
much about convergence because it works
very very well and it's always easy to
diagnose when there's convergence with a
power series all right so here's the
general setup the general setup is that
we have not just the coefficients one
all the time but any numbers dot dot dot
and we abbreviate that which this
summation notation this is the sum a and
X to the N N equals zero to infinity and
that's what's known as a power series
fortunately there's a very simple rule
about how power series converge and it's
the following there's a magic number R
which depends on these numbers here such
that and this thing is known as a radius
of convergence in the problem that we
had it's this number 1 here this thing
works for X less than 1 in our case it's
maybe X less than R so that's some
symmetric interval right that's the same
as minus R less than X less than R and
this is the so where there's convergence
ok where the series
converges converges and then there's the
region where every computation that you
give will give you nonsense
so X greater than R is the sum a and X
to the n diverges and x equals R is very
delicate borderline and will not be used
by us ok we're going to stick inside the
radius of convergence now the way you'll
be able to recognize this is the
following what always happens is that
these numbers tend to zero exponentially
fast fast for X in R and doesn't even
tend to zero at all for X greater than R
alright so so you'll just it'll be
totally obvious when you look at this
series here what's happening when X less
than R is that the numbers are getting
smaller and smaller
well I'm less than 1 when X is bigger
than 1 the numbers are getting bigger
and bigger there's no chance that the
series converges so that's going to be
the case with all power series there's
going to be a cut off and it'll be one
particular number and below that it'll
be obviously you have convergence and
you'll be able to do computations and
above that every formula will be wrong
and what makes sense so it's a very
clean thing there is this very subtle
borderline but we're not going to
discuss that in this in this class and
it's actually not used in direct studies
of power series
when the numbers are declining
exponentially fast it's just in other
words 1 over X okay the question is how
could why do I was I able to tell you
this word here Y was able to tell you
not only is it going to zero but it's
going at spinelli fast
I'm telling you extra information I'm
telling you it always goes exponentially
fast you can identify it in other words
in other words in other words you'll see
it and it will happen every single time
I'm just promising you that it works
that way and it's really for the same
reason that it works that way here that
these are powers and what's going on
over here is there it's close to powers
with these a ads all right there's a
long discussion of radius of convergence
in many textbooks but really it's it's
not necessary all right
for this purpose yeah the question was
how do you find our yes so I just said
there's a long discussion of how you
find the radius of convergence in
textbooks but we will we will not be
discussing that here and it won't be
necessary for you because it will be
obvious in any given series what the R
is it will always be either 1 or
infinity it will always work for all X
or maybe it'll stop at some point but it
will be very clear where it stops as it
is for the for the geometric series all
right ok so now I need to give you the
basic facts and give you a few examples
so why are we looking at these series
well the answer is we're looking at
these series because the role that they
play is exactly the reverse of this
inequality of this equation here that is
and this is a theme which I've tried to
emphasize throughout this course you can
read equality's in two directions both
are interesting typically you can think
I don't know what the value of this is
here's a way of evaluating it in other
words the left side the the right side
is a formula for the left side or you
can think
of the left side is being a formula for
the right side and the idea of series is
that they're flexible enough to
represent all of the functions that
we've encountered in this course this is
the tool which is very much like the
decimal expansion which allows you to
represent numbers like the square root
of 2 now we're going to be representing
all the numbers all the functions that
we know e to the X arc tangent sine
cosine all of those functions become
completely flexible and completely
available to us and computationally
available to us directly so that's
that's what this is a tool for and it's
just like decimal expansions giving you
a handle on all real numbers so here's
how it works
the rules for convergent power series
are just like polynomials all of the
manipulations that you do for power
caesars are essentially the same as for
polynomials so what kinds of things do
we do with polynomials we add them we
multiply them together we do
substitutions right we take one function
of another function we divide them okay
and these are all really not very
surprising operations and we'll be able
to do them with power series to the ones
that are interesting really interesting
for calculus are the last two we
differentiate them and we integrate them
and all of these operations will be able
to do for power series as well so now
let's explain the high points of this
which is mainly just the differentiation
and the integration part so if I take a
series like this and so forth the
formula for its derivative is just like
polynomials that's what I just said it's
just like pono
so the derivative of the constant is
zero the derivative of this term is a 1
this one is plus 2 a 2x this one is 3 a
3 x squared plus etc that's the formula
similarly if I integrate well there's an
unknown constant which I'm going to put
first rather than last which corresponds
sort of to the a 0 term which is going
to get wiped out that a 0 term suddenly
becomes a 0 x and the antiderivative of
this next term is a 1 x squared over 2
and the next term is a 2 X cubed over 3
and so forth yeah question is this a
series or a polynomial good question
it's a polynomial if it ends if it goes
on infinitely far then it's a series
they look practically the same
polynomials in series there's this
little dot dot dot here is this a series
or polynomial it's the same rule if it
stops at a finite stage this one stops
at a finite stage if it goes on forever
it goes on forever
numbers you can add up terms of X
ah so an interesting question so the
question that was just asked is I
thought that a series added up finite
numbers you could add up X that was that
was what you said right okay now notice
that I pulled that off on you by
changing the letter A to the letter X at
the very beginning of this commentary
here this is a series for each
individual value of X it's a number so
in other words if I plug in here x
equals 1/2 and you add 1 plus 1/2 plus
1/4 plus 1/8 and I'll get a number which
is 2 and I'll plug in a number over here
and I get a number on the other hand I
can do this for each value of x so the
interpretation of this is that it's a
function of X and similarly this is a
function of X it works when you plug in
the possible values of X between minus 1
and 1 so there's so that there's there's
really no distinction there it's just I
slipped it past you these are functions
of X and the notion of a power series
this is its idea that you put
coefficients on a series but then you
allow yourself the flexibility to stick
powers here and that's exactly what
we're what we're doing okay there are
other kinds of series where you stick
other interesting functions in here like
sines and cosines there are lots of
other series that people study and these
are the simplest ones and all of those
examples are extremely helpful for
representing functions but we're only
going to do this example here all right
so here are the the two rules and now
there's only one other complication here
which I have to explain to you
before giving you a bunch of examples to
show you that this works extremely well
and the last thing that I have to do for
you is explain to you something called
Taylor's formula Taylor's formula is the
way you get from the representation that
we're used to of functions to the
representation in the form of these
coefficients when I gave you the
function e to the X it didn't look like
a polynomial and we have to figure out
which of these guys it is if it's going
to fall into our category here and
here's the formula I'll explain to you
how it works in a second so the formula
is f of X turns out there's a formula in
terms of the derivatives of F namely you
differentiate n times and you evaluate
it at 0 and you divide by n factorial
multiplied by X to the N so here's the
here's Taylor's formula this tells you
what the Taylor series is now about half
of our job for the next few minutes is
going to be to give examples of this but
let me just explain to you why this has
to be if you pick out this number here
this is the a n the magic number a n
here so let's just illustrate it if f of
X happens to be a 0 plus a 1 X plus a 2
x squared plus a 3 X cube 2 plus dot dot
and now I differentiate it right I get a
1 plus 2 a 2 X plus 3 a 3 x squared if I
differentiate it another time I get 2 a
2 Plus 3 sorry 3 times 2 a 3 X plus a
dot dot and now a third time I get 3
times 2 a 3 plus
etc so this next term is really in
disguise 4 times 3 times 2x sorry a 4x
that's what really comes down if I kept
track of the fourth term there so now
here is my function but now you see if I
plug in x equals zero I can pick off the
third term f triple prime of zero is
equal to 3 times 2 times a 3 right
because all the rest of those terms when
I plug in 0 just zero
once here's the the formula and so the
pattern here is this and what's really
going on here is this is really 3 times
2 times 1 a 3 and in general a n is
equal to F and derivative divided by n
factorial and of course n factorial I
remind you is n times n minus 1 times n
minus 2 all the way down to 1 now
there's one more crazy convention which
is always used which is that there's
something very strange here down at 0
which is that zero factorials turns out
has to be set equal to one all right so
that's that's what you do in order to
make this formula work out and that's
one of the reasons for this convention
all right so my next goal is to is to
give you some examples and let's do
let's do a couple so here's well you
know I'm going to have to let you see a
few of them next time but let me just
let me just tell you this one which is
by far the most impressive so what
happens with e to the X if the function
is f of X is e to the X is that its
derivative is also e to the X and it's
second derivative is also e to the X and
it just keeps on going that way they're
all the same so that means that these
numbers in Taylor's formula in the
numerator the nth derivative is very
easy to evaluate it's just e to the X
and if I evaluate it at x equals zero I
just get 1 so all of those numerators
are 1 so the formula here is the sum N
equals 0 to infinity of 1 divided by n
factorial X to the N in particular we
now have an honest formula for e to the
first power which is just e which if I
plug it in x equals 1 I get 1 this is
the N equals 0 term plus 1 this is the N
equals 1 term plus 1 over 2 factorial
plus a 1 over 3 factorial plus 1 over 4
factorial all right so this is our first
honest formula for e and also this is
how you compute the exponential function
finally if you take a function like sine
X what you'll discover is that we can
complete this sort of strange business
that we did at the beginning of the
course or cosine X where we took the
linear and quadratic approximations now
we're going to get complete formulas for
these functions sine X turns out to be
equal to X minus X cubed over 3
factorial plus X to the fifth over 5
factorial minus X to the seventh over 7
factorial etc and cosine X is equal to
one minus x squared over two factorial
that's the same as this 2 here plus X to
the fourth over 4 factorial minus X to
the sixth over 6 factorial plus etc now
these may feel like they're hard to
memorize because I've just pulled them
out of a hat I do expect you to know
them they're actually extremely similar
formulas the exponential here just has
this collection of factorials the sine
is all the odd powers with alternating
signs and the cosine is all the even
powers with alternating signs so all
three of them form part of the same
family so this will actually make it
easier for you to remember rather than
harder and and so with that I'll leave
the practice on differentiation for next
time and good luck everybody I'll talk
to you individually